Please turn with me to Psalm 1.
Psalm 1.
We're starting a new series this morning in the book of Psalms.
And Psalms is a book made up of 150 Hebrew poems.
And these were written not only to be read, but also to be prayed,
and even to be sung.
And for thousands of years, they have been a faithful guide to God's people,
leading them in prayer and in praise.
And I hope they will be the same for us.
And the plan at the moment is to make our way through all 150 of them.
And as we work through them, we are going to probably maybe group some of them together,
but the plan is to go through the entire book.
So before you start working out the math in your head,
let me also say that this will be a series that we will also pause
and return to from time to time.
So don't think we're going to go through all just back to back.
And yeah, so we'll come back to it.
And all in all, it will probably take a decade or more for us to work through that.
And let me give you a couple reasons why I'm okay with that.
And I hope you are too.
One of those reasons is that we hope and pray that Trinity Fellowship will be around far longer than that.
By God's grace, we're praying that we'll plant a tree, so to speak,
a church that will be around for generations to come should the Lord tarry His coming.
But also why I'm okay with it taking a long time for us to work through this book specifically.
It might be different if we were in Job or something, but the Psalms,
this is a way of us underscoring the importance of prayer.
If this church is going to be built on a foundation that lasts,
prayer must be part of that foundation.
It is an essential part of that.
And regularly, we're turning to the Psalms and coming to God,
asking Him to teach us to pray and to pray again is going to be vital for us as a church,
both for those of us who are sat here now and those who will be here in years to come.
So let's begin by reading Psalm 1 together.
I'm not going to invite you, we don't always do this, but let's stand together
and we'll all read Psalm 1 with each other.
Let's begin.
Blessed is the man who walks not in the counsel of the wicked,
nor stands in the way of sinners, nor sits in the seat of scoffers,
but his delight is in the law of the Lord.
And on his law he meditates day and night.
He is like a tree planted by streams of water that yields its fruit in its season
and its leaf does not wither.
In all that he does, he prospers.
The wicked are not so, but are like chaff, let the wind drives away.
Therefore the wicked will not stand in the judgment,
nor sinners in the congregation of the righteous,
for the Lord knows the way of the righteous,
but the way of the wicked will perish.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that you would open our eyes that we might behold
wondrous things in your word.
And as we behold them, Lord, I pray that you would change us
more and more into the likeness of your Son Jesus.
And Lord, I pray that you would help us to teach,
that you would help us to pray as he prayed.
We ask all this in his name. Amen.
Well, given that the Psalms are a book of prayers,
it might seem a bit unusual or surprising that it actually
doesn't begin with a prayer.
So it begins with Psalm 1 and 2, and these are a kind of a
prologue that will then lead us into the prayers of the
book of Psalms.
All right, so Psalm 1 is part of that prologue.
Eugene Peterson described Psalms 1 and 2 as kind of
pre-prayers that put our feet on the path that goes from
a non-praying world where we're habitually distracted
and intimidated into the praying world where we come to
attention and practice adoration.
So prayer doesn't begin with us trying to get God's attention.
If we're thinking about it in that way, we're thinking
about it in the wrong direction.
Prayer begins with God getting our attention.
Peterson once again says, what is essential in prayer is
not that we learn to express ourselves,
but that we learn to answer God.
So Psalm 1 prepares us to pray by putting this God before
us and calling us to pay attention to him and see what
he says to us about himself in his Word.
Psalm 1 is also a path to blessing.
As Psalm 1 begins with the word, blessed.
Blessed is the man.
By the way, Psalm 2 ends with the same kind of thing,
calling us to see God's blessing once again.
Now word blessed communicates a sense of happiness,
a sense of well-being, of having received good from God
and responding in light of that.
When I tell the kids, maybe on a Saturday,
I want everybody to get in the car,
we're going somewhere, it's often that I'll then get
a symbol, where are we going?
And they're asking that question because they want to know,
are we going somewhere that I am actually going to look
forward to going or is this somewhere I'm going to have to
endure going, please let me know where we are going.
And when it comes to reading Scripture or praying to the Lord,
I wonder what feelings come up for you when it comes to
where you're heading.
It might be a sense of apprehension or a sense of
fulfilling a duty or it might even be a sense of dread
based on past experience, you know, trying that out
and kind of failing in that area.
It's amazing that the book of Psalms begins with that word
blessed because this is kind of setting the trajectory.
It's saying here is where we are going.
If we go where the Psalms are taking us,
where the Lord is taking us through His word here,
this is a place of blessing, a place of enjoyment.
So it's helping us to not be apprehensive
but to want where we're about to go.
We are heading for blessing.
And that life of blessing is put before us in the form of a man.
Blessed is the man.
So for the next few moments, what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this man together, this blessed man.
And we're going to look at three things.
We're going to see who he is.
We're going to see what he does.
We're going to see what he resembles.
Okay? So just walking through the Psalms.
First of all, who he is.
So we're just asking the question.
When it says blessed is the man, who is that man who is blessed?
Well, this man is put before us, we might say,
as both a pattern and a signpost.
So what do I mean by that?
First of all, it's a pattern in the sense that he is a type of the congregation.
So although the Psalm begins by speaking about the blessed man,
when you look at the end of the Psalm,
it's now talking about the congregation of the righteous.
So what it's been saying about this man all along it,
it actually speaks of God's people as a whole.
So what is true of them is true of him and vice versa.
Okay? Or what's true of him is true of them rather.
This may make me think about when it comes to like,
what's true of the blessed man being true of the congregation?
I was thinking about sitting at a barber shop back in the late 90s.
And then when you'd sit there, you'd see pictures of all these different men,
or you'd have a book where you're flipping through and seeing like,
well, which one do I want to look like?
And so at the time, it was a great time for haircuts.
You still had the kind of vanilla ice, you know, with a lightning strike through.
I'm sure some of you had that.
And then you had, I don't know, bowl cuts for in at the moment,
if you wanted a, you know, Jonathan Taylor Thomas kind of bowl cut,
or you had, if you were really cool, you could have bleached tips,
or you could go all the way and have the Eminem look.
My dad would have killed me had I done something like that.
But you kind of say, okay, well,
what is the man that I want to pattern how I look after?
Okay?
So here in the Psalm we have, here is the man.
All right?
But this man is put before us as a pattern.
Okay?
What is true of him?
We want to apply to our lives.
In other words, the path that he is on is the path of blessing.
Right?
That's what we want when we look at this man.
But when we look at the man here in light of the whole of Scripture,
we see an even greater depth when it comes to this man's identity.
That's what I mean by saying that he is also a signpost here,
because he's not just a type of the congregation,
he's also a type of Christ.
So he's pointing to Christ.
So Psalm 1 and 2 are this kind of gateway that put a picture of Christ before us,
before we actually enter into the Psalms.
So if you've ever read on Lord of the Rings or seen the movies,
so I'm going to nerd out for a second,
but you've got this river that's going into the entrance of Gondor
and they're kind of the fellowship or making their way down
and as they're going down the river, they see these two huge statues
kind of with their arm out and these are depictions of the kind of kings of old.
And so in a similar way in the book of Psalms,
you've got Psalms 1 and Psalm 2 putting a portrait of this king before us,
this picture of a king.
This is going to be explicit in Psalm 2 when we look at that together next week
when it's speaking about Christ there.
But I would also want to make the case that you can see that too in Psalm 1 as well.
So for example, in Deuteronomy 17, we're told that a king who is righteous
will be a king that will have his own copy of the law of God next to him.
At all times he will be reading that day and night.
And so as we read this Psalm together, what do we read about?
We read that the blessed man is someone who meditates on the word of God day and night.
So as we're reading what it says here about the blessed man, we have to think,
well is there a king who has ever fulfilled this description perfectly?
The answer will be, certainly not in the Old Testament when you look at all the kings that are there.
We might think, is there a person in history who's ever fulfilled this?
Well the answer is, yes there is. And it is Jesus.
So Jesus is the blessed man of Psalm 1.
So what it says about the blessed man really points us to Jesus.
He fulfills what we see here. He is Lord.
He is the Christ. He is the true King of God's people.
And he is also our representative.
So what is true of Christ is true of his congregation.
Our righteousness is found in Jesus.
A life of true blessing is found in Christ.
So Ephesians chapter 1 verse 3.
Remember that when we were in Ephesians?
Paul was blessing God the Father, the Father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who has blessed us in Christ with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places.
So the life of blessing in the New Testament put before us is the life that's given to us in Jesus.
That's where blessedness is found.
So that's who the blessed man is.
He's both Christ, but it's also the congregation of those who are in him.
But notice also with me what the blessed man does.
So this is a life that is given to us freely in Christ,
but that's not to say that it is a passive life where we just kind of sit around and experience blessedness.
It's an active life. It's a life where we trust and follow Christ.
So if we're going to know a life of blessing where we enjoy God and what he has given to us,
it will be a life of decisive action.
So we see this and what the blessed man declines as well as what he delights in.
So let's see this together. So what does he decline?
Blessed is the man who walks not in the counsel of the wicked,
nor stands in the way of sinners, nor sits in the seat of scoffers.
Just to summarize this, the blessed man refuses to listen to and follow the ways of the world.
You can see a downward progression here in terms of the danger that he's refusing.
There's a downward progression. It could be pointing us to a downward progression
and how it describes us even walking. So it starts off with walking and then standing and then finally sitting.
But the main kind of downward spiral is moving from giving your attention to ungodly ways of thinking,
ungodly philosophy, and then moving from our thinking to adapting to sinful ways of living.
And then finally coming to a place of full kind of acceptance among those who scoff at the things of God
because you're no different to them and even joining them in scoffing at the things of the Lord.
This is a danger that we all face. This is why it is in front of us here in the psalm.
It might come from peer pressure where you actually physically with somebody could be at school
or could be with work colleagues or whatever, but it doesn't have to be interacting with somebody in person,
especially when you think about this kind of age of information that we are in.
So the counsel of the ungodly can come in the form of a podcast or a good YouTube channel
or it could come in the form of an audiobook, right?
So we get information from all different directions now or bombarded with it.
The thing is if we are gorging ourselves on junk, at the very least we will not have an appetite
for the things that are best. We won't be able to delight ourselves in the things of the Lord
if our minds are full of everything else.
So it's clear here, filling our minds with things of the world will hinder us from enjoying the blessings of God.
So we read this in the New Testament, Romans 12, 1,
Do not be conformed to the things of this world,
but be transformed by the renewing of your minds, right?
So from our way of thinking to our way of living.
The life of blessing isn't just about what we receive but also about what we refuse.
So what are we actually refusing to shape our thoughts in our lives?
It's a worthwhile thing to think through, pray through.
But also we see he doesn't just decline the world, he delights in the Word of God.
So notice what happens next in verse 2.
It says, But, so in contrast, his delight is in the law of the Lord.
And on his law he meditates day and night.
So the one who experiences God's blessing doesn't just refuse the temptations of the world
and just kind of leave it at that.
No, he replaces them with something better, right?
So there's a kind of a self-denial that is involved here,
but it's not self-denial kind of as an end in and of itself, right?
We deny ourselves, yes, but that's not the end.
We deny ourselves with something better in view, okay?
So it's not just like I'm refusing to do some things and I'm just stepping into a life of self-denial,
but rather I'm embracing something better, alright?
So in that sense the problem isn't desire.
It's what we're feeding our desires all on.
So I love C.S. Lewis' weight of glory sermon.
I've never read it. I'd encourage you to read it.
There's a book called Weight of Glory that has it printed in there
and there's a kind of famous quote from it that I think really summarizes this point of refusing some things
but then delighting in God instead.
He says this in there. He said,
It would seem that our Lord finds our desires not too strong,
but too weak.
We are half-hearted creatures, fooling about with drink and sex and ambition.
When infinite joy is offered to us, like an ignorant child who wants to go on making mud pies in a slum
because he cannot imagine what is meant by the offer of a holiday at the sea,
we are far too easily pleased.
Do you see the picture there?
We're settling for something small when God is offering something so much better.
We're settling for the mud puddle when the Lord is offering us the holiday at the sea, so to speak.
So the blessed man shows us where greater pleasures are found.
They are found in the law of the Lord.
It says he delights in the law of the Lord.
So if you're wanting to know where is this greater pleasure to be found?
It is found in Scripture.
So it's found in...
So it talks about the law here.
Another way of saying that is the Torah.
So these are the first five books of the Old Testament.
And just kind of side note as a sort of introduction into the Psalms again.
The Psalms are broken up into five different books.
You've got the individual Psalms, five books,
and it's done in a way that almost echoes the Torah, the law.
So you've got the Torah is five books, and then you've got the Psalms has its five books as well.
So it's being put before us here as the Word of God,
just as they've relied on the Word of God in the Torah before,
so we can rely on the Word of God in the Psalms as well.
But why would he delight in the Bible?
Well, it's because of who speaks to us in Scripture.
Last week we saw God revealing Himself to His people in His Word.
It's in His Word that we come to know Him.
And the Lord is our ultimate joy.
And He is the source of all blessing.
And the blessings that last forever.
And if they could delight in the Torah, man, we have something to delight in.
A few days ago I was looking through some vinyl records,
and I'm getting addicted to doing that at the moment, and it's Dan and Kate's call.
So I was looking through these records, and I pulled out this record,
and I thought, this looks really, really good.
And I thought, this is way cheaper than it ought to be.
And I was about to get it.
And then I looked, and I saw a little sticker on it, and it said,
Disc 2, missing.
And so that was why it was cheap, because there was only one disc in this record.
The other one was gone, so I put it away. I wasn't interested.
Alright, so kind of a silly illustration.
But here we've got, when the Psalms are being written, they've got Disc 1.
And the blessed man is delighting Himself in what is here.
But imagine only having the Law, only having the Old Testament Scriptures.
But now we've got the whole thing, and it's not just that we've got twice as many verses to look at as they did.
No, it's that we're living after Jesus came.
So we now see what all this was pointing to.
And so we can see all of this being fulfilled in Jesus,
and all the blessings that we have been given in Him.
If they could delight in the Law of the Lord,
how much more can we delight in God's Word,
by being Jesus there, by the power of His Spirit?
So God has given us His Word to fuel our delight in Him.
And it's our desire to know Christ more that drives us to add fuel to the fire.
That we might come to see more of Jesus.
But what does that look like practically?
It says, on His Law, because He finds joy there,
He meditates day and night.
Or meditate, there just means to mutter.
So you don't think of like Eastern meditation or something like that.
So it's speaking God's Word kind of out loud to yourself.
In the book of Isaiah, it actually uses the same word to describe a lion growling over its prey.
So meditating on the Word involves having an appetite for it,
continually mulling it over, meditating day and night,
and getting it into your system, into your way of thinking in such a way that it shapes your thoughts.
It changes your life.
So continually mulling over God's Word.
So could I just simply but directly encourage you to do something to get in God's Word daily?
Read the Bible daily.
We have such a privilege to have our own copies of God's Word to get into.
And here we see that this isn't just like a...
I'm not talking like legalism here.
It's not a matter of like fulfill your duty.
It's like there is so much delight that is there for us to be found in knowing the Lord.
And if that's the case, why would we not want to come to God's Word each day?
Like whenever it works for you, however it works for you, pull out a Bible, listen to it.
But think it over and bring what you are listening to to the Lord in prayer.
Even if the prayer is, I have no idea what I'm reading right now.
Lord, please help me to read this.
But allow God's Word to make him known to you.
It's by the Word that his Spirit then opens our eyes to see more of the beauty and glory that is to be found in Jesus,
that we might delight in him.
So why would we not come to God's Word?
We used to live pretty close to my in-laws.
And I remember getting in the car with my father-in-law fairly often.
And if I was getting in the car with him in the morning, I knew at some point in the conversation,
he would say, you know, I was reading this morning in Exodus.
And it was that part where...
And he would start talking about what he was reading that morning.
And there would be some mornings where I'd be like, did I read this morning?
What did I read this morning?
And there was a...
I did feel a little bit of a pressure to, you know, not be the one who didn't read anything or couldn't remember what I read.
But looking back at that time and how often that would happen,
like what stands out most to me isn't that kind of that pressure to like not have something to say.
That's not what stands out to me.
What stands out to me is the example of somebody who is meditating on the Word of God day and night
and allowing that to shape his thinking throughout the day.
And that was just a real helpful influence in my life.
So this isn't about keeping a rule but growing in a relationship, right?
So how can you grow in a relationship with somebody that you don't know?
And how can we come to know more of the Lord?
This is what is driving us to his Word, who he is and the desire to know him more.
All right, so let's finally look at what the blessed man resembles.
All right, so he's delighting in the Word of God, meditating on it day and night.
And so, what's he like?
He is like, verse 3, a tree planted by streams of water that yields its fruit in its season.
And its leaf also does not wither.
In all that he does, he prospers.
Let's pause there for a second.
So he's like this tree planted by rivers of water.
It's a bit like what we read about in Jeremiah chapter 17 at the start of the service.
If you look at your worship guide there.
So there the blessed man is the one who is trusting in the Lord.
He is like a tree planted by water that sends out its roots by the stream.
It does not fear when the heat comes for its leaves remain green and is not anxious in the year of drought.
For it does not cease to bear fruit.
So if you are united to Jesus and drawing from his Word, meditating upon it day and night.
Your life with him and your fruitfulness isn't dependent on how harsh or pleasant the circumstances are of life.
Rather, you are connected to a water source that is deeper than what is happening on the surface.
It's connected to him.
One of my favorite trees is a Baobab tree.
I don't know if you've seen those in Africa.
When you see a Baobab tree in West Africa, you'll see them out in the Sahel Desert.
You've got these ginormous trees.
You think how in the world is this tree still alive right in the middle of this desert?
What you don't realize is that it has a root system that goes so far, way down deep into the ground.
It's able to draw from sources of water that are far beyond the surface of the desert.
When you look at that big trunk, it's able to store more water than a lot of trees can.
It's drawing it and it's filled up with that water and it bears fruit when the season comes despite being in a desert.
It reminds me of what is going on here.
You might look on the surface and think, how could you have a life of blessing spoken of here when this or the other is going on in our world or in your life?
It is found in being rooted and grounded in Jesus, in His Word, in a source that is beyond what can be stopped by the world.
So it talks about a couple of things.
One is the fruitfulness of the tree.
Notice that when we're desiring God and drawing from His Word, the result is a life of fruitfulness.
He's like a tree planted by streams of water, so that's being rooted in the Word that yields its fruit in its seasons.
Its leaf also does not wither.
So there's a picture of fruitfulness there.
So when we're rooted in Christ, drawing from His Word, God in his timing patiently brings about the fruit of His righteousness in our lives.
So we're like an evergreen whose leaf does not wither.
So there's a sense in which, in terms of like the evergreen side of it here, that He is our continual source of life.
And yet there's fruitfulness that comes in its season as well.
I don't want to read too much into the word season there, but if you're like me and the rest of us around, all the fruit doesn't all come at once.
So it's over time that we are being shaped into the lightness of Christ, bringing forth fruit in season.
It also speaks of prosperity here.
In all that He does, He prospers.
You also find this in the book of Joshua, right before leading God's people into the Promised Land.
God says to Joshua, Joshua 1-8,
This book of the law shall not depart from your mouth, but you shall meditate upon it day and night,
so that you may be careful to do according to all that is written in it, for then you will make your way prosperous, and you will have good success.
So what is the prosperity and success that we are promised?
What's promised is if you give me your credit card information before the end of the service, there's a life of blessing that is coming to you financially,
and you're going to have 10 times the amount of whatever you...
We hear that on TV, don't we?
What is the prosperity spoken of here?
It's not that.
In Psalms, actually, we see that material prosperity is not a fateful measure of success.
Now, we can be guided by the wisdom of God's Word, and there can be times when that leads to some kind of material prosperity.
Everything is in the Lord's hands.
We can give Him thanks for anything He gives us, and we ought to.
But material prosperity is not a fateful measure of success.
So Psalm 73 is a great Psalm to look at.
Psalmist talks about how he was envying the prosperity of the wicked around him.
He's like, I'm living this life of faithfulness to the Lord, righteousness.
And I'm not doing so well, and the world around me seems to be really prosperous.
He was envying the wicked.
But he says by the end, I'm not doing that anymore, and the reason he's not doing that anymore is because he sees their end.
He sees that the prosperity that they are enjoying is temporary prosperity.
The reality is though they're enjoying prosperity, now that is all the prosperity that they enjoy,
but they will enjoy because they are heading ultimately for destruction.
But when he thinks about his end, even though he doesn't enjoy the same kind of material prosperity here,
he's thinking about my end is a life where I know God as my portion forever.
And God is enough, and life with him goes on forever.
Nothing can take that away.
The blessings that I find in him are eternal blessings.
So the greatest prosperity is prosperity that lasts eternally.
If everything is taken away, you can't take that away.
So the greatest success is doing the will of God.
The greatest prosperity is receiving all of those blessings that are given to us in Christ that we read about in like in Ephesians 1.
So prospering in everything is doing everything by him and for him.
It is knowing his help and blessing in every area of life.
It is bearing the fruit of his spirit.
That is a work that lasts forever.
We see that also in how it speaks here because it speaks not just of the fruitfulness of the tree,
but also where it's heading in the future.
Notice what it describes.
It says in verse 4, the ungodly are not so, or the wicked are not so, but are like the chaff which the wind drives away.
So if the godly are like this tree that is planted, the ungodly are like chaff that the wind is going to drive away.
So the image of kind of winnowing is being used here where like grain is tossed up in a bit of a wind and when it's tossed up,
the chaff is blown away and the grain then drops.
So this is what is happening with the ungodly.
They are like the chaff that the wind easily blows away.
Things might feel okay now, but the reality is judgment is coming.
There is a day when we will all stand before God and give Him an account.
On that day there will be those who may be appeared to be stable and prosperous in this life,
but in the end we'll lose everything.
We will not stand on that day of judgment.
Therefore, verse 5, the wicked will not stand in the judgment,
but the sinners in the congregation of the righteous, for the Lord knows the way of the righteous,
but the way of the wicked will perish.
So people need to ask themselves like, is the thing that I'm living for going to matter in eternity?
Is the prosperity I'm aiming for, the success I'm aiming for, is that going to matter ultimately on the day of judgment?
So in the Psalm you've got this kind of reversal at the end.
Those who are once standing with the world in its ways will not then stand on the day of judgment.
Those who found that kind of place of belonging sitting among the scoffers will not find a place of belonging
where it matters most in the end when God dwells with His people forever.
In that place where in His presence there is fullness of joy.
And that is right hand, there are pleasures ever more. That's the place where it counts.
So these two ways are put before us here in stark contrast right the way through the entire Psalm really.
One is a road that leads to destruction away from the presence of the Lord.
The other is a road of blessing and life with God forever.
So the question is kind of put before us like which road are we on?
Are we on the road of that which will not last forever?
Are we on the road with the Lord leading to this eternal blessing?
So 1 John chapter 2 and verse 17 says this, the world is passing away,
but he who does the will of God abides forever.
So the thing that determines which of those roads you are on is whether or not you know the Lord now.
Whether or not you know him and are with him then will be whether or not you know him now.
So what does it say for the Lord knows the way of the righteous?
Knows, the knowledge here that's spoken of is that it's an intimate relational knowledge.
It is a relational knowledge of the Lord and his relationship to us.
So does those who have a relationship with the Lord who will know the blessing of being with him forever?
So we need to ask the question, well how can we then know him?
How do we know the Lord?
How do we know him as our source of life and blessing?
The answer is through faith in the blessed man.
Jesus, are we in him?
So let's allow this Psalm to do its work in us.
Point us to see Jesus and to see more of him in his word.
To put our faith in him.
And to find him to be our greatest joy.
So let's pray together.
Well thank you so much for giving us your word which points us to this life of a blessing that lasts forever.
A blessing of knowing you and enjoying you forever.
So Lord I pray that you would help us to turn our eyes away from those things that will not last in the end.
And to fix our eyes on Jesus above all else.
Lord I pray that you would give us a hunger for him and a desire for him that is stronger than our desire for anything else.
And Lord I pray that as we desire him, Lord I pray that you would help us to put our trust in him.
Lord I pray that you would help us to know you more and more and to trust you more and more.
Lord I pray that you would help us to be a people who are coming to your word day and night that we might see more and more of you.
Lord I thank you that what we see in you and the blessings that we receive from you will last forever and forever.
So Lord I pray that you would help us to trust in you.
It's another blessing of being in Christ.
Lord I pray that as we are in him and growing in him together that you would make us a people of prayer.
In Jesus name. Amen.